came to America two years ago and you
opened a bank account what was the main
issue you said you had it wasn't really
an issue as such but they basically told
me that I was only going to be
going to be and that really surprised me
but okay what's the problem with being
FDIC insured up to a quarter of a
million dollars that's a lot of money no
or not is it a lot of money
it sounds like 250
degrees sounds like a lot of money but
but it's not because What's it gonna get
you after money printing inflation Wars
it's not going to get you anything it
kind of get you a nice house with
several bedrooms for a family in a good
area it actually can't really get you
anything so what are they trying to do
what are you saying then well the point
is well firstly what if I want to
deposit
one million dollars with the bank right
the rest of it 750 000. right exactly
right so what's the point in me then
striving to want to make more money
if I'm not going to be covered what's
the point and it's also it's not just
it's that but it's also that they make
you think that 250 000 is a lot of money
because it's about your relationship
with that number so by saying oh you're
only covered up to 250k it's like oh you
don't need more than that don't worry
you don't need more than that but that's
all you need and so naturally you don't
strive to make more because they've sort
of they've sort of capped it in a way so
psychological cap you're saying yes
thank you it's a psychological cap
because if they said to you
um oh you're insured up to one million
dollars suddenly you feel like oh I
should have one million dollars right
it's like okay I should have one million
dollars and what about you were telling
me the bank uh the tellers what did they
say to you about everyone's happy about
the customers or something yes when you
question that yeah so when I when I
questioned them I said
um I said I said what I really showed up
to 250k and they said well yeah most our
customers are happy with that and I was
like wow I'm the first person that's
questioned this cap and to me that was
just such a crazy example of how the
average American is is so brainwashed
it's so is so happy to just be told
that's all you're allowed to how the
system keeps you poor right it's how the
system keeps you poor because again it's
like this it's it's a it's like a psyop
it's a psychological cap don't make more
than 258 you don't you don't need more
than 250k don't worry about it you don't
need more any moment the bigger money
you know that that's for that's for the
elites that's like the accredited
investor in this country but that's
another video it's like oh can I have a
million dollars now you can't get into
the secret credited investor Club
no no exactly six 250k that's all you
need don't strive for more yeah stay
interesting thank you for that